here in the Mission District of San
Francisco where hundreds have gathered
to support the family members of the
forty three generations of the IOC opera
school they've come all the way from
guerrero mexico here the man justice and
they're not going to stop they're going
all the way here and speak in front of
United Nation they're meeting up with
two other caravans of family members
traveling across the United States it's
been over six months since the students
were attacked by police and disappear
the Mexican government called off the
search in January blaming a drug gang
for the deaths the government hasn't
produced enough DNA evidence to satisfy
neither the families nor human rights
organizations who say there's more to
the story one no piensas innocent esta
noche que lo que vivir mas were the
koalas la memoria
yeah perdi la llamada es muy triste es
muy feo verdad en este momento qual es
su miedo más Grande
grandes como puede hacer la gente de los
Estados Unidos la gente de equipo de ser
mucho mucho que hacer por el gobierno de
aqui en tierra la muchacha covina exigen
o con vida por que muerto no esta una
prueba y diga esta muerto y sabemos que
si la na internationales impression da
Gama strip ice for our sober well amiga
forma de esos Vassily bien porque en
where no magic ah no no save a castigar
asimismo nunca SE na parque de este en
funny dad subra ratito